we can't believe we have to say goodbye
to you and eMac we have loved getting to
know you Cyrus the facts and the rest of
your family and friends but despite our
greatest efforts your show is ending so
you have us wondering what is going to
happen to all of you after season 3
where is life going to take you and most
importantly what are we going to do
without you Andy Mack is in its third
and final season but there is still so
much we don't know about our favorite
characters keep watching to find out
what will happen to Andy in the gang
after the series finale Cyrus we
absolutely love Cyrus he has been such a
great friend to Andy and Buffy sure he
isn't perfect but overall he is always
there for his besties Cyrus made
headlines as the first openly gay main
character on the Disney Channel and the
moment he told TJ how he felt was so
sweet after season three we're pretty
sure Cyrus and TJ are going to date for
awhile and it will make high school so
much better since they will have each
other
eventually they will part ways TJ will
get a basketball scholarship to one
college and Cyrus will go to another he
gives such great advice that he decides
to become a therapist like his parents
he will be super successful and he will
help kids just like himself
stop fighting I'll never stop you did
your best but this part have to face by
myself he'll definitely be able to help
other kids with coming outs then he'll
fall in love with a great man and adopt
some children we just know that Cyrus is
going to do awesome things Buffy we are
sad to say goodbye to Buffy she is such
a good friend even though it always
seems like she has a boy drama she's
been there for Andy and isn't afraid to
tell her what she needs to hear after
season 3 Buffy will go on to be a
basketball and track star in high school
she will finally unofficially end things
with Walker so what's your answer
will you go to fall formal with me no
she and Marty will keep flirting for a
couple of years but eventually they will
realize they are meant to be Buffy is a
go-getter and decorated math she will
get a track scholarship for a
prestigious university
she will major in business which will be
perfect for her math skills
she'll be president of several clubs in
college she will become a super
successful businesswoman and eventually
by her own basketball team she and Marty
will get married and
one kid who was also an awesome athlete
Buffy definitely has a great future
ahead of her
Jonah Jonah has grown a lot as a
character on Andy Mack he used to go
through girlfriends like crazy and he
ever wanted to deal with his feelings
but Andy helped him to learn to overcome
that what you think Jonah and Libby will
date for one year or so in high school I
like but like a lot of teen
relationships they'll move on from each
other Jonah will head to college to
study music he'll start an intramural
Ultimate Frisbee team there for fun he
will meet the girl of his dreams playing
frisbee Jonah will continue to write
songs
he will get discovered by a producer
after college and to get our record deal
he'll become a huge star with a lot of
fans we just don't really see Jonah
having kids he'll be too busy as a
superstar he will stay really friendly
and down-to-earth he will also start a
scholarship fund for young musicians
like himself he'll be really big into
advocating for music education in
schools because it helped him so much
Becks oh thanks she has learned how to
be a grown-up and has ended up being a
great mom to Andy I'm not your sister
I'm Your Mother
but it always seems like there is some
sort of drama with her she has just
called off her wedding to Bowie
but she's just nervous we know that she
and Bowie are meant to be together she
will realize she loves him they'll get
married in a beautiful small ceremony
Bex and Bowie will live with Andy while
Andy finishes high school when she goes
off to college they will travel the
world together for a few years but they
will still be around to support Andy
when she needs them Becks will get
pregnant again and they'll actually get
to raise a baby together
Andy will basically act like vex as the
cool older sister they will eventually
be the world's coolest grandparents
dexon caelius relationship will continue
to improve and cilia will be really
proud of her oldest daughter Andy we
can't talk about the future of the and
eMac casts without talking about Andy
Andy has matured so much over the past
three seasons and she is going to have a
great life in high school she will have
a couple of serious boyfriends so you're
going to camp for a long for eight weeks
processing she will continue to get
better at art her art teacher will
encourage her to apply to a super elite
art school in Paris she'll go to college
in France and become a successful artist
she'll spend a year backpacking across
Europe which will make Beck's a super
proud she'll get a little jealous of her
baby sister because she didn't grow up
with Beck's and Bowie as parents but
she'll get over it and turn into an
awesome big sister eventually she'll
fall in love with another artist they
will get married and have three kids she
will stay good friends with Cyrus and
Buffy and they'll get together every
year to reconnect she will be a
bridesmaid in both of their weddings and
they'll be in hers she will be a great
mom as a mix between Celia and Becks
what do you think will happen to all of
the antimatter 'he's after season three
tell us your theories in the comments
thanks for watching and don't forget to
Like and subscribe we'll see you next
time on the things
[Music]